the thing you all want to know this
morning is is nazzanin coming home the
woman who will know more than anybody
else is the foreign secretary she's with
us good morning thank you for joining
good morning kate is she coming home
well we are working very hard and i've
made a priority as foreign secretary to
secure the release of nazanin
anushay and morad who are all detained
in iran
we've also made it a priority to
pay the debt that we owe to iran but i
can't say anything more than that i'm
afraid tell us about the debt 400
million quid there abouts as a result of
um tanks that were paid for but they're
never delivered where are we with that
well we have been clear this is a
legitimate debt that we do
oh iran and we have been seeking ways to
pay it how can we pay it if they're a
sanction and they can they can't get the
money
well i can't go into details i'm afraid
but we are looking for ways to pay it
and we have been very clear
it is a legitimate debt that the united
kingdom owes iran
could it be through as has been
suggested by a previous foreign
secretary through
medical equipment and medicines and the
like
well as i've said we're looking at ways
of
paying that debt
that is a separate issue from the issue
of the
detainees it was one of the first things
i did as foreign secretary was met the
iranian foreign minister to urge him to
release the unfairly d
the unfairly detained british people
namely nazanin
murad and anushay we continue to work
round the clock to achieve that come
back to that in a second if i could just
seek further clarification as far as the
debt is concerned has that actually been
paid in one way or another at the moment
as we speak this morning
i i can't say anything more about that
uh at this moment okay what can you tell
us about where the three uh dual
nationals are right now
i'm afraid kay i also can't say anything
about that when at this stage
what i can tell you
is that we are working extremely hard to
secure the release of the detainees we
have been working very hard to do that
over the past few months we are in
discussions as the prime minister has
made clear but i can't say anything else
at this stage i'm very very sorry no no
not to be able to say anything else and
i know how desperately
uh the families want to see
uh their loved ones back but i i really
can't say anything else at this point of
course and we're just asking questions
that everybody at home will be asking
this morning everybody very excited
about the prospect of these three deal
nationals wiley being able to come home
have has the dial moved at all for over
the last few
days as i say we have been having
discussions i met my counterpart the
uranium foreign minister back in
september
we've been in regular touch since
we do have a team in tehran but i
absolutely can't say anything else at
this stage do you know when you might be
able to say more
no i don't okay um let's move on then
but i mean obviously we are incredibly
hopeful that it looks as though the tone
has changed somewhat as far as dealing
with iran is concerned and there have
been lots of times when her husband has
been desperate and um her young daughter
has now of course come to live in the uk
so they are hoping against hope that she
and the other two
it's a desperate situation and um
you know my hearts are with the families
who have suffered so greatly and of
course with nazanin and nishi and of
course murad as well yeah okay um so
obviously you'll update us as soon as
you know more but at this stage you
can't tell we know that she got her
passport back yesterday obviously that's
what her mp tweeted but that that's
moving in the right direction isn't it i
can't say any more i'm afraid okay
okay the team in tehran obviously um is
is an interesting move as well and
you've been on my program before and
said that it is a legitimate debt that
does need to be paid so you know we'll
take what we can from that um as far as
ukraine is concerned we also heard that
um
three british nationals were killed in
the explosion near the poland border
over the weekend do we know any more
about that
we don't have any more information about
that what we know is that vladimir
putin's plans are not going according to
plan he's not making the progress
expected and we know the sanctions that
we've put on are working they're having
a debilitating effect on the russian
economy yesterday we announced 370 more
designations of individuals and
oligarchs we've now designated over a
thousand individuals and entities more
than either the us or the eu so we are
really putting the pressure on
everything from banks to the oil and gas
industry to the luxury goods industry
and to individuals in russia and those
sanctions are really beginning to bite
and we're working very very closely with
our allies to do this because putin
only understands strength and he will
only
understand when we successfully
stop the funding into the russian war
machine by debilitating the russian
economy but also we're helping the
ukrainians with their struggle by
providing the defensive weapons
my colleague defense secretary has
supplied n laws into ukraine we're
working with other allies to do that we
just need to step up these efforts
because what we can see is that his
offensive isn't working it's of course
having a horrendous and devastating
effect on the ukrainian people we're
doing all we can to support with
humanitarian aid but what we need to do
now is step up that pressure on putin to
secure the withdrawal from ukraine and
to end this appalling war
will there be more sanctions to come
there will be more sanctions to come uh
as i've said we've already sanctioned
over a thousand individuals and entities
we've sanctioned ten uh major banks
along with the united states the eu has
sanctioned three banks we'd like to see
them sanction even more banks
we want to see a full swift freeze
currently we've frozen swift for a
number of banks but not all of them and
we want to see a complete
elimination of dependency on russian oil
and gas the uk of
you we have said that by the end of this
year we will stop all gas all oil
imports from russia many european
countries are very dependent on oil and
gas we want to help them reduce oil and
gas dependency say that russia has
nowhere to fund
this appalling war machine
what would more sanctions look like
well more sanctions on individuals
we've got more individuals on our list
more companies
and more sanctions collectively with our
allies
on
the oil and gas industry as well as
encouraging more countries to put
sanctions on so 141 countries voted
against russia at the un general
assembly we want to see them follow suit
we've seen countries like south korea
and japan put sanctions on but we'd like
to see all 141 put sanctions on russia
so they're completely isolated in the
international community how do we stop
these oligarchs running away though like
abramovic seems to have done okay we've
got some of um
his some would say ill-gotten gains
staying here in the uk but you know
managed to flee the country pretty
quickly this is why it's so important to
work with our allies across the g7 and
beyond so this simply is nowhere for
these oligarchs to hide there is nowhere
it is legitimate for them to live their
lifestyles uh have their yachts or have
their planes and that's why we've had a
total ban
on russian planes into the united
kingdom uh we've also done the same for
vessels and we're encouraging all of our
allies to do that and we're working with
our g7 partners on the task force on
targeting these assets under what
circumstances would abramovich be
welcomed back to the uk
well we we've put these sanctions on
because of the appalling war that putin
has unleashed and the first thing we
need to see putin do is withdraw his
troops
from ukraine and then we need to see an
end to the threats to ukraine
we need a
positive settlement for ukraine that
guarantees
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity and
who knows what might happen after that
clearly
ukraine has already been devastated you
know we've seen the appalling scenes in
the cities across ukraine and there will
need to be discussions about how
how those um
how the rebuilding is paid for i'm not
going to speculate on exactly uh what
will happen in the future but we need to
see those who contributed to this
appalling war suffer the consequences as
of as i'm afraid to say uh the people of
ukraine have suffered the consequences
so just to go back abramovic would be
welcome back into the uk once the war in
ukraine has ended i haven't said that no
i'm asking i haven't no i haven't i
haven't said that because i'm saying
that even if the war was to end and i
fear we are not near the end
at this stage you know huge devastation
has been caused lives have been lost as
a result of this war and there will need
to be a reckoning
with all the people who supported putin
including abramovich and the like
including ibrahimovic and the oligarch
cash etc that has been seized that you
think could potentially be used to pay
for uh the rebuilding of ukraine we're
not ruling anything out at this stage
as far as ukraine um and and the
president is concerned he spoke of
course to parliament didn't he at uh i
think it was the end of last week he was
very well received when he did that um
what more support can we offer the
people of ukraine at the moment of
course we're you know the great british
public are opening their doors and their
homes to those that that can arrive and
a hundred thousand people have offered
their properties um a room in their
properties so far but what else can the
british at the british government do to
support the ukrainian people well the
two things the ukrainian government want
most is us to put more sanctions on
russia
and for us to support with more
defensive weapons into ukraine and we
are stepping up on both of those we're
now leading in terms of the number of
sanctions we put we've put on uh russian
oligarchs and individuals but we're also
way ahead in terms of our sanctions on
banks we want to encourage people to do
more and we also want to reduce european
dependence on oil and gas and the second
thing they want is defensive weapons and
we've supplied end laws we're now
looking at the star streak
air defense missiles
the third thing we are doing is
supplying humanitarian aid we're the
second biggest humanitarian donor
to ukraine
after the united states we're supplying
electricity generators we're flying
children out for
hospital treatment in the united kingdom
uh we're supplying
food we're supplying
medicines
and we we continue to do that working
with the neighboring countries
particularly poland uh who are facing of
course a major a major flee of
refugees into poland so we are we are
working really hard at the front line
it's obviously difficult uh to get into
some of those besieged cities we're
working with the international agencies
uh who are doing that but we're doing
all we can to supply the humanitarian
age and british people have been
incredibly generous uh the deck appeals
already raised 130 million
which is way ahead of i think many other
appeals we're almost out of time but i
just want to ask you about saudi arabia
which of course is where the prime
minister is at the moment as a woman you
know i find it very difficult to
comprehend the way that women are
treated in a country like saudi you have
to do business with them
how do you go about that do you have to
hold your nose
i do not agree with
all of the policies of the saudi
government of course i do
do not but the reality is
that we are facing
an aggressor in vladimir putin who is
wantonly destroying a neighboring
sovereign nation and we do need to work
with countries across the world to find
alternative sources of oil and gas and
russia is a threat not just to regional
security but to global security
so
we have to work with all of our
uh allies around the world including
saudi arabia to find alternative sources
saudi arabia is not a global security
threat in the way that russia is and we
have to work with them we have to work
terrible
i'm not i am not condoning the policies
of saudi arabia what i'm saying is we
are in a
existential threat about european
security and global security and we need
to find alternative sources of oil and
gas so we are no longer dependent on
vladimir putin and his appalling regime
i have to let you go um uh be great to
talk to you for longer but we must leave
it there thank you very much hopefully
next time you come we'll be celebrating
the fact that three uh dual nationals
are back home thank you very much